comme l'an dernier le valais dévoilé sur
les réseaux sociaux avant sa sortie
officielle le dimanche gras ce qui va à
l'encontre de la tradition pour certains
pour maintenir la tradition je crois il
faut vraiment autour de cela qu'il y à
suspense
et c'est justement le but pas qui est
vert pour vous c'est dommage qu'on sache
déjà
oui oui tout à fait il faut vraiment que
le suspect ne peuvent perdurer qu'on se
demande qui va quéval écouter ça sert à
quoi de le savoir à l'avancé tout le
charme de la chose donc on attendra
dimanche et kaka et ses collaborateurs
sont amenés à revoir furieux de voir
leur travail ainsi livré sur les réseaux
sociaux pour faire le buzz sans filtre
et sans respect
franchement je ne trouve pas vraiment
les mots qu'il faut pour condamner un
petit peu ces gestes ça n'a pas de sens
du toit à mes yeux donc voilà des petits
par rapport à ça mais sinon le travail
là bas ce ferry le bal sera d'aller où
normalement sans surprise que c'est une
responsabilité d'une part de dévoiler
une qui n'a pas été livré
d'autre part de faire
le buzz auquel l'action kellogg pour moi
c'est navrant je pense que bon il faut
bien aussi qu'on vous met en garde et
qu'on puisse respecter les oeuvres de la
ville de fort de france réfléchit d'ores
et déjà un moyen de sécuriser davantage
la réalisation du val pour éviter que
les fuites ne se reproduise